welcome to this 15-minute game against
wrong rock okay so maybe I need to give
him some choices to pick up the wrong
rook always a good idea so he went for d
5 against my 93 okay I'm playing the
original reti opening this is an
interesting move order especially after
like as played see success now I have
the right range of setups I can play d4
for the Slav I can play g3 which is
interesting i can play III I play g3
here why choice the the issue with this
move on is actually the move D 5 D for
which is sort of a benoni reversed and a
bit of a yeah matter of taste if you
want this is white ok yes respond at
night if six already you know well here
i can go Bishop g2 which would actually
allow him to take the pawn and this is a
real gambit it's not so easy to get it
back I can play b3 to cover it but this
has one drawback and this is DC for BC
45 tricky more it's 95 queen d 4 losses
apiece however this isn't so often
played and that's another idea this is
quincy to this has so recently that you
can also just cover the pawn of course
the queen is committed very early to see
too young ok i normally allow the
capture and play this game better why
not here black very often tends to not
take it
it's probably the most critical move to
take the pawn but then there are of
course solid alternatives like Bishop g4
which is a bit tricky after 95 Bishop f5
which is which is also a bit tricky
because you know what happens after the
capture and queen bee three attacking b7
and yeah while taking as mentioned is
the most critical if you have this is
black and one term and rock solid way to
play i can actually recommend them the
move g6 very solid to play just Bishop
g7 castles Bishop g4 but some very
harmonious way to develop it's nothing
that will disturb white greatly but it's
um as mentioned a very sound approach
you can also play how much was just
about to mention that you can also play
e6 and let's just ignore all of that and
continue to develop the King side which
very likely leads to him to catalan okay
I guess I mean he can still take but it
didn't take the move before so probably
you won't do that now and it's not the
end of the world i'm going to play a
form against that okay so just a normal
development yeah i mean here i should
probably play deform it's just very a
normal-looking news yeah that's a very
solid set up that he chosen and a very
playable one I only know of one really
good setup and this is some what I'm
going to UM i'm going to play now and
this is with them 92
night fd2 that is but the weird move but
it's good I'm trying just trying to
figure out can i play Knight c3 first
maybe I might take on see form it's
unlikely but maybe he can do that yeah
okay so I'll start with this move I know
that it looks a valley unnatural to put
this on d 2 but of course the point is
that wide wants to play a form and here
we go I'm attending to play efore after
de 94 94 94 I have an excellent knight
on e4 with them very comfortable space
advantage note that the night on d 2
also frees the bishop putting pressure
on d5 so black cannot so easily play on
e5 p.m. which could be an idea is 65 at
the moment I just have enough pressure
on d5 so that I can take it and if you
take see for this would be a substantial
mistake as night see form gets the night
into the game again with the temple and
it has an excellent post on c forum so
black normally um place them a little
strength and it moves like rook e8 here
I think maybe I'm now they have he's
going for that so he for now is a very
logical okay that's not use time on that
yeah he must take it for now there's
simply no other move I guess okay and of
course I'm going to take with the night
and this is also very very logical TM
young here the problem is where to go
with the bishop of course c 70 or 75
eight you know I guess they well c7
looks very natural because it keeps an
eye on the five firm scram okay he how
interesting what is his idea maybe it is
C 5 maybe it's a five mmhmm yeah I
really don't know the next step is what
to do with my bishop III have for those
are a good squares he also might play
Knight f6 and the next move this is Sam
in fact rather likely that he wants to
try to exchange my my night on on your
form I wonder if a plane with like
Bishop e3 email I can you play e5 is
this a good wolf or am I just better
after d4 d5
mhm ne5 d5 he takes on d5 cd59 f6 yeah
it's certainly not bad for white that's
clear
what I'm wondering is if I should maybe
play Knight c3 you just prophylactically
move it away so that after a 5d five he
is almost forced to capture and then I
have 95 which would be very nice
establishing on the piece on d5 on see
father also have d5 yeah I like that
idea really okay come on let's let's do
that it keeps my options open in regards
to the c1 bishop it's not really that
clear if it is better placed on III on
f4 on e3 it might be helpful because it
lends extra protection to the depot it
might pressurize the Queen side when air
for it is of course giving more
influence on the center yeah TM what do
I do now Bishop f4 you might play Bishop
d 6 which is not a fantastic move but I
don't want to exchange really this
should be three looks very normal
putting increasing the control over C 5
so that C fibers are to play
yeah of course it's all about the c8
bishop as usual in Queens gambit
structures with e6 the bishop on c8 is
just not a great piece if you compare it
especially to the g2 bishop now let the
story of the Catalan opening that why
this just basing his play on this
excellent bishop yeah it's not so easy
for black to to play I mean what exactly
SF yeah you end with this kind of semi
useful moves okay um what is my IDM I
have a very technical idea d 5 which is
probably good for small advantage but
it's not so let logical to open up the
bishop really i mean i can do that but i
need better or i probably can do it
under better circumstances let's say
let's put it this way can what I'm not
so sure about where my queen should go
but what I know is if i move the Queen
to c 2 and B 3 my plane I g4 so I'll
just put an end to that it makes my
queen more flexible Knight g4 would
would be annoying because I don't want
to move the bishop because defaults
dropping let's say queen bee three I
would have played the night before
awesome what's what's really am really a
bit of bit annoying okay and where to go
now I'm thinking about queen bee three
this is some very young logical square
I'd get some some pressure on the
queenside at the loser
the rooks to be am connected hmm maybe
yeah yeah I'm wondering about b6 now
maybe then d 50 is not doing that okay
yeah okay so I guess I'll i put the
rooks and the center now but the way I
exactly then progress d 1 and C 1 not
sure about the most of the order of it
yeah all right down by two minutes so
I'll play a normal and all looking move
and see what he's doing and I'm not sure
if this is the best setup but it's
certainly an okay set up and now that I
think of it I could have thought about
Bishop f4 for a moment as Bishop d6 is
dropping the b7 porn and it's not
entirely clear okay but this is maybe an
additional idea like Bishop f4 if he
moves the quirky move the Queen
voluntarily that's an interesting moves
yeah yeah it is interesting especially
because i have d hive now the kind of
opening move that I that I thought about
before but now it actually comes with
the temple on the Queen and we would
have we would get an exchange you would
get an exchange on b3 and wonder maybe
just night a fall there's also an idea
relief
I have 95 available yeah I like that
more even come on let's do that you will
probably take it does not I had 95
anyway so I'm here it's useful to do
always check the porn breaks he cannot
place he 5 i'll just take it and Bill
Bell b7 and so on possible to play and
if I he also cannot play so this looks
like quite a comfortable position he
might try be 62 to prepare c5 but that's
not without its problems as well yeah I
wonder I wonder if I I don't know really
if I should play a form to once and for
all um shut down the five IDM I mean
he's he cannot play it at the moment now
it does not make much sense really at
the moment to play a phone he is far
away from from playing that move okay so
um what about the night here is this
really a well-placed piece does not
really it's not really
fulfill a useful role what it might do
is it it might be a tactical detective
from a technical point if you'd might be
interesting let's say look atchu rook da
one night takes be 60 make three moves
in a row and win the game that's not
entirely pointless it's not easy to
prevent actually him he must do a sum
must play some some weird-looking moves
to prevent it yeah it's this really good
looks it looks a bit artificial I'm
always suspicious if moose don't don't
look natural I mean a natural-looking
move would be something like Knight c3
maybe get it back now yeah okay but I
still think it's dangerous so I'm not
quite sure what black is going to do
against it without weakening himself I
mean I'm doing things that he probably
does not want to do yeah it's probably
not bad I mean he has absolutely no
counter play him
hmm really not sure what what he should
do now it's a not so apparent yeah
that's one idea but still rook rook here
to a one or should i do should I drop
back now to see three okay let's let's
do this first let's do this first and
see if he really wants to play a five
maybe that's not such a big deal
actually I but okay wait we went on a
five I probably have d5 and this would
open up the position really to my
advantage yeah
really I'm not sure pigs yeah prob
probably it will open up to my to my
benefit with d5 it does not need to play
a five and now he can of course play a
sensible waiting move like let's say
look to look to see right here Brooke
easy eight if I drop back oh his playing
is playing really a committal move Wow
so if I'm just take it what exactly see
doing i'm taking a seven at the end and
why not it takes pawn takes Knight c5
Bishop c5 Bishop c5 rugby three they are
can come on this is this is good for
white I don't I don't believe it
ok so just rope chicks oh yeah I guess
so if he takes now with the bishop I
just take a 7-eleven it's it's simply a
simply a pawn it's a double porn okay
but still i also have entered on the
seventh-ranked some if it takes with the
pond i think i just play room 1 a 3 and
then take it on the next move on a seven
it's no way to protect the pawn
and once I'm on a seven I mean this is
an excellent piece on the seventh-ranked
the look maybe maybe I even had a shrub
c6 the previous move like Bishop c6 to
be five maybe well I actually even had a
better move than Luke a three I could
have played before this would have been
would have been even stronger ok but ok
I let's let's let's just grab hear that
that's perfectly fine and now I have no
I have Lucas seven maybe maybe rook is
seven King takes Bishop c5 check Wow
mmm that's not bad really okay what is
this count climbing it's not it's not as
straightforward when I believe also
because he has the intermediate check on
d1 yeah it's got rook rook d3 maybe
okay yeah rook to e3 but I have Luke I
am here even here I've rue Kade just
exchanging the rooks ah come on it's
it's probably the simplest way to play
considering that i'm a bit down on time
it's probably not the best move but
mm-hmm it keeps things simple the end
game with rooks off should be a should
be excellent ok and here well I can't
take I can play with a five still all
okay come on let's do that get this off
okay so he wants to I understand he
wants to put a blockade on before okay
well maybe
but still it's still very good night
takes our play Bishop e7 controlling the
a6 square so that night a 6 or 96 is not
possible and I intend to play before
giving a porn back to to free the free
the the sea porn let me check this I
mean the problem is that here pretty
quickly approaches with the king
yeah my king is not it's not playing at
the moment this is that's really an
issue yeah I started I cannot play
without that key yeah that's the most
active move probably need to play b3 ham
or what about nc6 it's not possible
because of from King d6 okay
yeah I want and must go to the king to
see form and term let's this takes quite
a while
you
96 may be attending night to deform
no I cannot take this this is not not
winning at all time morning okay i'm
giving up this pawn him to get the King
activated yeah forgot about that one
okay not in really I'm not in trouble
here but I of course completely miss
plated so I had had much better much
better ways to play that's very clear
p3i take it of course and that's not not
on knight c6 and planking see form
can I deform might might save him the
the bishop on f3 is hanging it's really
really really bad maybe I'm this I
picked the wrong square down and I can
take seasick with the check I take here
that's 95 check after check here
I know he loses one of the pawns wow
it's the the right colored bishop that's
very important oh we play without
increment I completely forgot about that
to be honest I had the increment game
yesterday
yeah for 12 seconds but I'll manage yeah
the very bad end game play with the Emmy
lab I simply allowed hard to watch them
check check check mate Jim now let's
let's check this end game I mean ok the
look exchange it wasn't the best
possible way to hear here's a very
important point actually here before
just just enter the game in so leave
this is much much better technically
much easier to play because i get rid of
my only weakness in a very favorable way
he needs to take it obviously otherwise
i'll play even be five and then take a
seven so he needs to take it drew k 7
and this is just curtains the dope on
here supported by the two bishops that's
very easy I mean okay this this is also
winning but it's not it's not so clear
cut and the rook trait assume is
probably making it a bit difficult but
still it should win yeah I'm not sure
about that really I I was afraid that we
get to this stage and he gets to reform
thats it's really almost almost the
blockade
hmm yeah and yes really i mean this this
is my extra porn it's not not too
convincing and it's somewhat better
provide because i always have before i'm
getting a getting a passer but it's far
less than I then I should have okay well
this is this is really questionable i
guess i'm not i'm not risking much i
believe but it's it's it's still
questionable yeah and here i don't i
shouldn't go to every really i should go
to g2 on f3 this was a bad spot simply
because of what he played but but here
here he must play differently i will be
three wins for blood yeah at all it
already was a bit tricky me i need to
play Bishop do you one here which is not
great I really I really screwed his
endgame up totally yeah Bishop g3 versa
if I got that it was a check on c6
really this is just good for black or
even winning I mean I cannot take
because of 94 it should be for is some
yeah something like that and I mean
black has an extra poor now which is
funny because he started the endgame
being a pawn down yeah that was really
bad yeah I guess I need to I need to
yeah just just do that yeah but I this
is all obviously I'm already a big big
fail compared to to what I had I mean
even that is probably better does this
kind of sacrifice check yeah come on
incoming challenge of course not no
check the ship's e5 check King somewhere
and before I this is even better
compared look at those pawns yeah this
is difficult for black to defend it's
probably better than the game though
it's not necessary at all i can i can do
just just a couple of strengthening
moves king everyone or whatever yeah
that was bad I mean I wanted to keep it
simple but I made life hard for myself
it's 0 here also good suggestion by by
the by the computer like that check must
go back and then we should be certainly
that's also very good very good now
sorry this simply stops the play against
the pond and once I have my king in the
game it's it's it's it's an easier thing
to play I get the King over here and
then play before to free up the sea porn
yeah that's also quite easy yeah that
technical claim alright thanks for
watching